…たくみさん。
はい
おぉ！
ニキビは
何でできるのかを
ご存知でしょうか？
さまざまな
要因があると思います…
※肝臓の不調や肝臓障害などの病気の可能性もあります。
ちょっとたくみがやっぱお肌を気にしている訳なんですよ・・・。
そんな彼のお肌を改善しようと思って…
・・・・・
おぉっし！！
１週間あれば変わる！
マジ！？
そんな彼の
お肌を
改善すべく
わたくし、素晴らしいものを
準備しました！
コチラ‼
ありがｔ…
だぁあいっ！！
ドサドサッ…（物音）
こちら
３１本入り！
というわけでたくみさん。
ニキビに困っていると…
困っています。
それ「かいちゅうび」に困っていますか？
ずっと悩んでいるんですけど…
いろんなヤツ試したんですけど…きｋ
そんなたくみ副社長なんですけども…
というものをご存知でしょうか？
わかりますよ！プルプルしてるやつ
(無言タイム)
こちら…「コラーゲンCゼリー」というヤツで…
ﾀﾞｲｼﾞｮﾌﾞｶ？
何か一応いろいろと調べた結果…
これがオレの見た中では一番コラーゲンが配合率が高かった…
ﾀﾞｲｼﾞｮﾌﾞｶ?
そもそもコラーゲンとは…
厳密にいうと…
簡単に説明すると…
なんと…
肌に多く含まれておりまして･･･
※肌ではなく顔
ﾍﾟｼｯ
だから肌にいいといわれているらしいんです。
…ﾊｧ
いいや大丈夫、大丈夫だって
オレが何とかするよ
本当に
※しかし、ヒトでの信頼できるほどの有効性について国立健康・栄養研究所はコラーゲンを食べても「美肌」「関節」に期待する効果が出るかどうかは不明であるとの見解を示している
wiki参照
任せ…ﾌﾌﾌ
ちょっと笑っているでしょ！
だって…
笑っているでしょ‼
お肌対全にはいろんな方法があると思うんですけども…
まず彼には…まず「栄養」ですね。
体のもとになるものからまず改善していきたいというわけで…
コラーゲンのゼリー20箱用意しました
1箱あたり7万7千5百mmｇコラーゲンがはいってるので
ﾆﾔｧ
グラム数に直すと…
こちらに今コラーゲンが存在します。
・・・
(ΦωΦ)ﾌﾌﾌｸｯ…
じゃあ、たくみさん。
はい。
とりあえず…
カード…ﾀﾞﾊﾊｯ
…って！笑っってま…笑ってるよっ!!
コラーゲンを摂取してみましょう。
まずは体の中からキレイになってもらおうという企画でございます。
というわけで今回は…
一気にいくよ！
いける？
お肌のためなら
なるべく…
肌の変化を見ていきましょう。
早速食べていきましょう!
よしっ！！
ピィ～!（ホイッスル）
じゃぁいただきます
はい
じゃぁ、いただきま～す
どうぞ！
（ここでこの商品についてです・・・）
原材料
豚皮、穀類、ビーフエキス、酵母エキス、ポークエキス、卵黄粉末、オリゴ糖、D-ソルビトール、加工デンプン、増粘安定剤(CMC)、セルロース、乳酸、乳酸Na、着色料(カラメル)、保存料(ソルビン酸)、ポリグルタミン酸、緑茶抽出物
成分
1本(約2g)あたり
エネルギー・・・約6kcal
たんぱく質・・・16%以上
脂質・・・9%以上
水分・・・20%以下
用法及び用量
1日あたり1本を目安にお召し上がり下さい。
ホント!?
おいしいよこれ
あぁありあり
それなら全然あり
ホント!?
少年ら堪能中・・・now loading
ん～っ・・・
あっ、おいしいね
はい、早くも…
色グロッ!!
色がすごいっ！
企画続行中･･･
原材料にあったソルビン酸について・・・
ソルビン酸は成長不順、腎臓肥大や発がん性などの可能性があります。
《衝撃の真実に苦笑い》
原材料にあったオリゴ糖について
オリゴ糖には危険性はありませんが一度に大量摂取するとおなかをゆるくしてしまいます
なんか…お肌に変化はない…
※今更ですがこの企画はとても危険です。絶対に真似しないでください。
はい。
素晴らしい
7万7千5百ミリグラム
1か月分終了で～す
！！
絶好調だよ？
大丈夫？
ちょろいなぁ～。
来週には肌がキレイになっているのかもしれませんね。
たくみ～～～～～！！
説明読みたい方は一時停止推奨
！！警告！！
タンパク質をとりすぎると･･･
たんぱく質をたくさん食べることは、腎臓に負担になる可能性があります。腎臓には、腎炎、腎不全、ネフローゼ症候群などの病気があります。
あと尿として排出されるときには、カルシウムも一緒に排出されてしまい、骨粗鬆症の可能性も発生してしまいます
コラーゲンを豊富に含む食品には高脂質のものが多いため、高カロリーになりがちです。
そのため太ってしまったり、ニキビや吹き出ものなどのトラブルを起こす原因となります。
コラーゲン成分が高濃度に体内へ摂取されたことによって、体内の水分がコラーゲンに引き寄せられ、腸内で水分不足が起きている、と考えられます＝便秘
なんでも取り過ぎはやめましょう・・・